vivax est à arn messagers ont changé la
donne dans la lutte à la pandémie de
lakovic 19 parce que nouveau est à
l'avant-garde de la génétique ils ont
inquiété plusieurs pourtant ils sont
d'une efficacité exceptionnelle ma
collègue galuchat berdou nous explique
comment il fonctionne
[Musique]
il est minuscule mais depuis un an il a
accompli de grandes choses la rn message
est un tout petit bout de matériel
génétique présent naturellement dans
toutes nos cellules et qui est l'élément
central des premiers vaccins déployés
contre la coved 19 les tout premiers
vaccins à arn être approuvé une petite
révolution dans le domaine
voici comment ça marche
dans nos cellules le noyau abrite notre
code génétique
notre adn qui contient toutes les
instructions nécessaires à leur
fonctionnement
selon les besoins des cellules des
parties de ce code sont copiées en arn
messagers la rn sort ensuite du noyau
pour transmettre ses instructions au
reste de la cellule pour qu'elle
fabrique les protéines dont elle a
besoin
l'idée des vaccins à arn messagers c'est
d'introduire de nouvelles instructions
dans nos cellules un brin da et rennes
qui ressemble à celui d'un virus et qui
va amener la cellule à fabriquer des
parties de ce virus
elle va ensuite présenté ses protéines
du virus à notre système immunitaire qui
va apprendre à les reconnaître et les
combattre entre autres avec des
anticorps
ça c'est la version simple évidemment la
réalité est plus complexe
ça a pris plus de trois décennies de
recherches pour qu'on réussisse à créer
des vaccins à arn qui fonctionne
d'abord parce que nos cellules ne sont
pas des passoires il fallait trouver une
manière d'y faire entrer l'air dans les
vaccins actuels on lan capsules dans des
particules de lipides
aussi la rn est une molécule instable il
est rapidement dégradée par l'organisme
il ya donc fallu ajuster la recette des
vaccins jusqu'à ce qu'ils produisent
assez de protéines pour bien stimuler
notre système immunitaire
les vaccins à arn contre lacko vite 19
se sont avérées remarquablement efficace
pour prévenir la maladie
après des centaines de millions de
vaccinations on constate que les effets
secondaires qu'ils peuvent provoquer
sont généralement bénins
certaines personnes ont quand même des
inquiétudes par exemple que la rn puisse
altérer notre code génétique
notre adn
la rn des vaccins entre dans la cellule
mais pas dans son noyau où se trouve la
dn il ne peut donc pas le modifier
par ailleurs les cellules qui reçoivent
le vaccin et produisent des protéines
virales vont être rapidement identifiés
et détruite par notre système
immunitaire
c'est justement l'objectif des vaccins
[Musique]
par rapport à d'autres types de vaccins
ce arn messagers en plusieurs avantages
en particulier ils peuvent être produits
et modifier rapidement par exemple pour
être adapté au nouveau variant d'un
virus
d'une certaine manière la comédie 19 est
arrivée juste au moment où cette
technologie était prête à faire ses
preuves
parmi ceux qui en ont profité
l'entreprise moderna test est déjà des
vaccins à arn avant la pandémie
aujourd'hui ils en ont 16 à l'essai
contre une série de virus entre autres
le vih qui résiste aux vaccins
expérimentaux depuis près de 40 ans
après la cua vide qui sait peut-être que
la rn nous aidera à affronter une autre
pandémie celle du sida
à